hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage here in los angeles california
we are having demos up here throughout
the week and we are here with Madden I'm
your host Mike McCarty here with Nick
margarita is going guys and I'm here
with Madden a teen executive producer
Sean Grady everybody and creative
director Mike Young huh thanks for
coming on guys having us appreciate it
so at the EA conference the other day we
saw a lot about Madden 18 most notably
is longshot got a new mode that you know
it's kind of tackling a narrative a
story for this character that we're
going to kind of see through Mike I'm
will talk to you about that you said
we're talking before this you said this
is been in the works for a while like
four years something yeah I always
started this journey about four years
ago we wanted to you know bring more
emotion to the game and we wanted to
have a great story so we worked on the
script for two years and reworked it and
reworked it and we wanted to feel it
this story was worth bringing to life
and making it playable and then why it
took maybe four years was I don't think
we could have done a story of this
ambition without the Frostbite engine
which Madden's getting this year but
when you see the story you see it's very
epic in scope the number of environments
there's over 40 environments there's
over 45 characters all shapes and sizes
you know we have eight year old kids we
have 80 year old men we have women you
know the whole gamut and Madden before
that had really just been built and
optimized to action on the field guys
and pads but when you see this journey
that Devon Wade character takes we
couldn't have done it without this
engine and that's why I took so long but
we wanted to get it right you talked
about that journey that he takes uh I
mean like it showed like kind of like
his whole life right that we're seeing
unfold before us well it's really
interesting because our story is more of
an origin story of Devon Wade this kid
from Texas who was a great high school
quarterback lived his dream and got to
go to Texas was a long horn quarterback
and we're showing a little bit that
something went off the rails but now our
story picks up at this year's regional
combine and it's the story of Devon and
his best friend giving their dream one
more shot from the combine to the draft
day so we don't even see davic about
hand oh gosh
the NFL okay gotcha um yeah I mean it
seems like I mean like we were talking
before the show it seems like you know
like FIFA did the journey and then NBA
Live this year is bringing out the one
kind of thing it seems like it's
inspired by FIFA the journey but you
said you've been working on it for even
longer since before seven FIFA 17
brought the generally without Lex hunter
but it's interesting what is the what
was the poll to actually bring this kind
of narrative this story into a sports
game because like across the board EA
sports games are kind of doing this and
it seems like you know a it seems like
it's bringing a new crowd and that might
not you know might typically be
intimidated by these four schemes that
they don't know much about but also be
it just seems like it's lending more
context to again character to these
games yeah I think my inspiration was
I'm a huge sports game where I grew up
you know wanting to be in the NHL then
workout obviously um but I've always
played all the sports games and but I'm
also a story gamer and I found myself
wanting that quality of storytelling
that I'd seen a telltale game or a last
of us that made it so much more
relatable like blast of us you know you
think about it's really a story of a
father and a daughter and it makes you
care about going on that long journey
with them and I felt like sports games
can have that and that's what we went
about trying to do and your second point
is we'd treated this like a campaign
mode we have so many NFL fans that are
gamers that are intimidated by Madden
year after year they want to be part of
this culture I think this is a great
mode to allow them to come in because so
many of the game mechanics if you're a
gamer you've played them you've
branching dialogue QuickTime events
we've made so many of these little mini
games and you know brought to life
all these little interactions along the
way so it feels like a playable movie
and I think that's going to be very
welcoming and story will bring more
people in because they just care about
characters and games and it just happens
to be set in this football world one of
the cool things about that that we
haven't talked much about because it's a
movie quality experience you can play it
is super seamless these guys have done
something quite innovative I think where
it feels like the game never loads I
mean once you go into the store it just
starts to run you're going into
environments and playing game mechanics
you're coming out and seeing a cinematic
you know it's just it's just very
seamless throughout which I just don't
think that's been done
it's sports but let alone really in-game
so it's quite an impressive feat it was
really important to have that quality
because you find that you'd be really
immersed in this emotional moment or
this action moment and then all of a
sudden you load out for 30 seconds your
attention wanes we wanted to keep you so
engrossed in the story that we had this
huge tech investment to pull this off
and it is a subtle thing but you don't
feel like you ever want to get out
you're just in in it like a movie
this sounds like cinematic right like
you must have approached it from kind of
like how are you going to transition
from scene to scene how is it going to
feel like one singular thing rather than
these discrete chapters yeah transitions
were so important so you know the
musical score going across scenes and
having establishing shots so you know
where these characters are and all of it
you know just has this quality and
craftsmanship to it I think the way we
shot it like a film you know similar to
how avatar films digital films but we
have our cinematographer Brian Murray's
actually got a camera and he's filming
our scenes like a movie of the starpower
a long shot is incredible
we have my Hershel alley who just won
the Academy Award yeah as Devon Wade's
father we have JR lemon who played in
the NFL he's an actor on the night shift
he had such a great performance as Devon
Wade and then we got Scott Porter from
Friday Night Lights yeah so just an
amazing cast and then we have amazing
cameos by guys like Dan Marino Chad
Ochocinco so I think there's that other
side of it which is the fandom of
feeling like you spent time with the Dan
Marino that we're delivering to not just
the story yeah the last Dan Marino can
be like I think it was a spin Chara
another probe this one's like a story
but this was out damn place was a it was
he's he plays himself and he's sharing
these personal stories with Devin like
he's a big brother so he's this mentor
to Devin Wade who really has to overcome
some obstacles to get to the NFL but
it's really cool that to feel like
you're playing catch with Dan Marino
being coached by Dan Marino it adds a
level of you know impact
yeah and NFL immersion to this yeah I
imagine like some you just mentioned
Friday Night Lights I was going to ask
what kind of
influences are like affecting this story
yeah so people had that have been
playing it often say oh this feels like
I'm playing Friday Night Lights
obviously we have the Scott Porter
connection but really it's about the
setting you know small-town Texas
football a very intimate we get to know
so many these people in the town
we're playing high school football games
in this but the tone is really inspired
by Friday at lights things like hard
knocks probably the biggest movie
influence was Good Will Hunting there
kind of social structure
Devon Wade is similar to the Matt Damon
character and that he's kind of fighting
against his own potential okay he's got
this uber supportive you know Ben
Affleck played the uber supportive loyal
best friend that wants his friend to
succeed more than he wants himself to
succeed and that's where the
similarities between Devin and cold come
in cool it sounds ambitious to say the
least it has ambitious yeah that's us
for years right it's very ambitious for
sure yeah and I guess like I did want
out like while you I'm not sure what you
can and can't talk about but outside of
long shot although that is does sound
like the most interesting thing that
Medan has going for it as far as like
innovation and whatnot but like it
outside of that what are some like big
changes you want to make to the core
Matt in like game modes
yeah the probably the biggest thing is
much squads which is on the floor if you
played this week it is the return of all
19 play which is a top requested feature
from our community from our fans last
time we had in the game was back in man
25 we brought it back in a bigger better
way inside of our most played mode which
was Ultimate Team it's three versus
three human control players in
traditional 11 V 11 Madden football the
way that it's maybe unique and different
now is that there's three different
roles that you can play as you can play
as the head coach the offensive
coordinator the defensive coordinator
the head coach is kind of a nice entry
level way to get into it if you're not a
great Madden player and from your
ultimate team you're bringing your
stadium in your uniform so you want to
really make any big decisions offensive
coordinators going to bring in their
offensive lineup and they're going to
call off the plays as you might guess
they'll be the quarterback at the start
of the play and then the defensive
coordinator will call defensive plays so
we see our you know kind of ultimate
team fans bringing some of their friends
and kind of training them up how to play
and then you merge your teams together
we get asked a lot like why do it inside
of ultimate team and
and the reason is they're just like a
wrapper of replayability inside of it
because you're earning stuff all the
time you're getting rewards for what you
do you're building your kind of team
together then sharing that with your
friends cool name I guess yeah guess
aside from that kind of competitive mode
going towards the more traditional style
you guys made the move to frostbite this
year so what kind of improvements were
made possible by moving to frostbite
yeah well first and foremost long shot
frankly would not be possible at the
scale that we did it as Mike said so it
certainly allowed that the journey
pulled it off inside of the frostbite
engine as well for us it's I mean the
visuals just kind of leap off the page
you know we we feel Madden 17 was a
really strong looking game we feel like
it stands up with any other sports title
and other games in the industry so we
first and foremost had to beat that
visually with frostbite engine but
really what the engine does is allow us
to approach photo realism and that's
that's what we feel our goal is some of
the things you're going to see in the
game that are new are some of our
pregame sequences have stadium exteriors
or fireworks going off you can see that
the players running into the field and
kind of celebrating like they do and
just the lighting the character details
or just you know quite epic and
approaching that photorealism goal that
we're shooting for yeah and then I guess
gameplay wise I know last year one of
the biggest improvements was you know
breaking tackles kind of controlling
your offensive players and defensive
players where if you tried to tackle me
I could get away from that are there any
other new improvements that make players
more mobile or things like that this
year for Madden 18 yeah we always kind
of improve the animation across the
board we do a lot of mocap every year we
had new animations we fine-tune kind of
all the mechanics and how they feel you
know they are they reacting to your
button input so that as the players have
played on the floor this week they've
noticed that that called that out the
the two kind of specific gameplay
features that people are excited about
one is it advanced target passing
mechanic where essentially you can
identify receiver you want to throw to
and then move a little targeting system
to an exact spot on the field and then
the receiver and the defender of course
will both run at the ball so it is a
challenging mechanic we call it a skill
gap mechanic where you have to lab with
it a bit to really figure out how to use
it once you figure it out it's a pretty
cool mechanic and the other one is on
defense essentially we're telling you
who you're supposed to cover at all
times whether your man covers your zone
coverage it's a visual assist element
that's very similar to what you see in
an NBA game you know you'll have like a
little line with
circle drawn to the guy you're supposed
to cover so we we make sense to add that
to football so now you can get off the
defensive line which is where everybody
plays on defense to the stage it's okay
to go play a linebacker it's okay to
play a cornerback is will help you out I
guess I have one last question how do
you go about balancing a game in which
obj exists say you're sitting with two
Giants fans yeah it's funny say that cuz
that's a big catch you know everybody
was feeling like we had too many of
these big cats and we were so fancy
hired by that - obviously well I'll
speak to that so one way we do we've got
three play styles this year
one is arcade which is new and you're
gonna get a lot of obj catches in arcade
so now my young 10 year old son wants to
play a game like that we've got
simulation play style which is kind of
traditional Madden that our fans are
used to mean Madden is a simulation game
at the end of the day and then we've got
a competitive play style to kind of
remove some of the dice rolls under the
hoods and makes it more about your stick
skills and that's that's what you play
online so that's how we balance it out
any updated celebrations as well there
is I think you've probably heard the
NFL's loosened the rules oh yeah there's
a few new celebrations of the game yeah
boy - that cool well Sean and Mike
thanks so much for come on our stage I
love it thanks yeah thanks for having us
yeah have a good rest of the show
appreciate it we shut it for everybody
watching at home we will have more demos
outside of Madden we have FIFO we have
NBA live we will have a lot of other
kind of games coming out of games bots
III staged throughout the week so stay
tuned we'll see you then